โอเคสวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะครูนิกโอเคสวัสดี
ครูเรียมแล้วก็สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนใช่ค่ะ
วันนี้มาเจอกันเอ๊ะดูครูนิกสว่างไสวจัง
เลยนะคะสว่างไสวใช่เพราะว่าวันนี้เนี่ย
คือตอนนี้ที่อเมริกาครับเมืองที่ครูนิก
อยู่เนี่ยตอนเช้าแล้วมันก็เลยมีแดดส่อง
เพราะว่าเนี่ยเดี๋ยวครูนิกจะให้ดูดูแป๊บ
นึงอันนี้คือห้องทำงานคุูนิกแล้วคือเนี่ย
หน้าต่าง
ว้าวมันก็เลยถ้าตอนเช้าเนี่ยแสงมันก็มา
เต็มๆแต่ถ้าตอนกลางคืนก็มืดตอนกลางคืนก็
จะเห็นเหมือนที่อยู่วิดีโอก่อนมาเหมือน
ที่เราเคยดูกันในวิดีโอก่อนๆแล้วที่บ้าน
เนี่ยแฟนครูนิดเขาไม่ชอบไฟสีขาวทุกอย่าง
มันก็จะเป็นโคมไฟเล็กเล็กๆเป็นไฟสีส้มที่
แบบมันไม่ได้ช่วยมากพอเปิดแล้วรู้สึกว่า
เหมือนอยู่ในที่เราเคยพูดเล่นกันว่า
เหมือนอยู่ในนรกเพราะมันแดงๆ
เออใช่ๆๆอยู่ในเตาอบอ่ะเตาอบไมโครเวฟอะไร
พวกเนี้ยที่แบบมันสีส้มๆแดงๆเป็นแสงที่ดู
แล้วรู้สึกร้อนใช่มันร้อนอืออืมใช่แต่ว่า
ตอนนี้ค่ะครูนิเป็นเวลาเอ่อเอ่อ
35 ที่ประเทศไทยโอเคครับเอ้ียมต้องเขียน
แบบนี้มั้ยเต้องเขียน 31 จากนั้นน่ะคือ
99:00 นนะเช้าแล้วนะอๆๆต้อง 21 เพราะว่า
คนไทยจะถ้าเขียนมันจะเขียนเป็นตัวเลข 1-24
อืใช่ถ้าเป็นนาฬิกาครับอืใช่ๆค่ะ
2135 ใช่
วันพุธของครุนิกตอนนี้วันเอ้ยไม่ใช่สิวัน
อังคารอ่ะงงไปหมดแล้วงงไปหมดแล้วอ้าวัน
วันนี้วันอังคารใช่วันเดียวกันอังคารวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะครูนิกวันที่ 4 ครับอืวัน
ที่ 4 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคม
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับอืแล้วปีค.ศล่ะคะ
20  2  2
อืโอเคอแต่ที่นี่ก็ยังสว่างอยู่นะคะครู
นิกสว่างเพราะเพราะไฟขาวหรือ
เปล่าเพราะครูนิกอ่ะครูนิกครูนิกสังเกต
ว่ามันไม่มีแงวหน้าต่างข้างหลังะ
ใช่ิมอยากให้ดูแบบหน้าต่างเรมมากเลยแต่
ว่ามันเป็นกล้องที่ติดกับโน้ตบุ๊ก
อ๋อระวังระวังเพราะว่าถ้าหยิบแล้วเดี๋ยว
มันจะหล่นได้ใช่คุณนิกเคยคุณนิกเคยเหมือน
กับจะให้เพื่อนดูอะไรในคอมได้แหละใน
โน้ตบุ๊กแต่คุณนิกก็ไม่คิดว่าคือตอนนั้น
ก็ไม่รู้ว่าคิดอะไรคุณนิก็หยิบขอหยิบ
โน้ตบุ๊กเนี่ยแล้วก็เหมือนกับจะหมุนให้
เพื่อนดูแต่คือจริงๆอ่ะให้เพื่อนเดินมาดู
ตรงทางเราก็ได้ะเกิดอะไรขึ้นมั้ยก็เกิด
ครับเพราะว่าพอนี่ๆๆมาดูมาดูแล้วก็หยิบ
แล้วก็กำลังหมุนแล้วก็อคว่ำโน้ตบุ๊กนี่
ตุ๊บลงโต๊ะไปเลยแต่ไม่มีอะไรมากเพราะว่า
มันเป็นโต๊ะแบบคือมันไม่ได้ห่างกันมาก
เหมือนกับอันเนี้ยถือโน้ตบุ๊กรถโต๊ะมัน
อยู่ตรงนี้มันก็แค่แป๊กแค่นั้นตกใจยคะครู
นิก็ตกใจนิดนิดหน่อยตกใจนิดหน่อยใช่อื
เนี่ยวันนี้แบบเพิ่งจะสลับกันเรียมมา
บันทึกคลิปตอนกลางคืนครูนิกบันทึกคลิปตอน
กลางวันใช่ใช่วันนี้เรียมก็เลยแบบมีคำถาม
ขึ้นมาค่ะครูนิกครับว่าแต่ละวันเนี่ยเรา
ทำอะไรกันบ้างแล้วเราจัดการเวลากันยังไง
อืเพราะว่าบางทีเราก็บันทึกคลิปในวันและ
เวลาที่แบบไม่เหมือนเดิมทุกสัปดาห์อือฮึ
อืเริ่มที่ครูนิกก่อนแล้วกันครูนิกทำยัง
ไงคือกิจวัตรประจำวันก่อนมยกิจวัตรประจำ
วันครูนิกทำอะไรอ่ะอย่างเนี่ยตอนเนี้ยเออ
คุณนิกต้องบอกก่อนว่าถ้าตอนเช้าคุณนิจะ
กินกาแฟเยอะเวลาถ้าอัดวดีโอ
สอนตอนเช้าเนี่ยหรือทำอะไรตอนเช้านัก
เรียนหรือครูที่ครูนิกจะสอนด้วยเนี่ยจะ
เห็นว่ากินกาแฟ
ตลอดใช่อืที่บอกว่าเยอะนี่เยอะขนาดไหนกี่
แก้วคะก็อย่างน้อยนะจริงๆเมื่อก่อนเนี่ย
วันอืทุกวันนี้ก็เหมือนกันอย่างน้อย 3
แก้ว
อเมริกาโน่เหรอใช่ๆคนนี้กินจะกินกาแฟดำซะ
ส่วนใหญ่ถ้าเป็นกาแฟแต่อย่างอื่นอย่าง
ม็อกค่าหรือกาแฟที่มีนมเนี่ยคุณนิกจะกิน
บ้างแต่น้อยมากอาจจะเดือนละ 1 ครั้ง 2
ครั้งครับ
อืแต่ถ้าเป็นนมเนี่ยคุณนิก็จะกินนมวัวไม่
ได้กินนมวัวแล้วเป็นยังไงคะของคุณนิถ้า
กินนมวัวแล้วคครูนิกจะปวดท้องครับคือ
เมื่อก่อนน่ะคุณนิดกินนมวัวได้แต่ว่าตอน
เนี้ยคือเปลี่ยนมากินพวกนมถั่วเหลืองกับ
นมแอลมอนด์แล้วพอเปลี่ยนไปได้หลายๆปีกลับ
ไปกินนมวัวแล้วมันไม่ได้เพราะร่างกายเรา
มันเปลี่ยนไปแล้ว
อ๋อใช่แล้วเวลาที่ครูนิกอยู่บ้านตื่นขึ้น
มาแล้วครูนิกก็แบบดื่มกาแฟก่อนเลย
หรอใช่
ครับใช่ชีวิตใช้ชีวิตได้ด้วยกาแฟใช่แต่
ว่าไม่ไม่ต้องใส่ในตารางนะไม่ต้องใส่่ใน
ปฏิทินว่าโอเคตื่นเช้าอย่างแรกกินกาแฟ
คือคือมันมันทำทุกวันจนมันชินไปแล้วคือ
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยก็ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ติดกาแฟแบบ
นี้แต่เหมือนกับว่าคือคุณนิกมีเหตุผลด้วย
นะที่กินกาแฟเนี่ยเพราะว่าคูณนิกเป็นคน
เข้าห้องน้ำบ่อยไม่บ่อยแล้วกาแฟดำมันช่วย
ให้คุณนิไปเข้าห้องน้ำไป
ไปไปเราจะพูดยังไงดีไปเอาของไม่ดีในร่าง
กายออกทำไมอ่ะทำไมเราต้องอายทำไมเราต้อง
อายแล้วก็ไปห้องเข้าห้องน้ำก็ได้นะใช่ไป
เข้าห้องน้ำเข้าห้องน้ำไปขับถ่ายใช่ไปขับ
ถ่ายเพราะปกติถ้าคุณนิกจะพูดคุณนิจะพูด
อีกคำนึงพูด
[เพลง]
ว่าเ้านักเรียนก็รู้นะใช่ต้องไปขี้ก่อนนะ
เออนั่นแหละแค่นั้นแหละจบแค่นั้นแหละเออ
ออก็นั่นแหละครับก็เพราะว่าคุณนิกไม่ค่อย
ได้เมื่อก่อนไม่ค่อยได้เข้าห้องน้ำบ่อยก็
เลยมากินกาแฟดำเรามันช่วยคุณนิกก็เลยกิน
ทุกวันตอนเช้า
อืหลังจากนั้นถ้าเกิดครูนี้ก็มาเริ่มทำ
งานเลยมั้ยคะ
เอ่อเริ่มมั้ยก็พออย่างแรกเนี่ยพอกินกาแฟ
หรือทำข้าวเช้าแล้วพอข้าวเช้าเสร็จเราก็
คุณนิกะก็จะดูในโทรศัพท์ว่าวันนี้ต้องทำ
อะไรบ้างเพราะว่าครูนิกเนี่ยจะเก็บทุก
อย่างไว้ในโทรศัพท์
อืก็คือใช้แบบคาน้าหรือเปล่าหรือว่าใช้
อะไรใช่่ครับมันก็เหมือนกับเป็นปฏิทินของ
ในโทรศัพท์นี่แหละเค้าก็มันก็จะบอกว่า
เหมือนกันเลยวันนี้คุณนิก็จะจดเอาไว้วัน
นี้ต้องทำอะไรบ้างแล้วก็คือตอนนี้
โทรศัพท์มันก็เค้าเรียกว่ายังไงดีมันก็
ฉลาดเพราะว่าเวลาเรามีอีเมลหรือว่าเราใช้
แอปอะไรแล้วมันมีเหมือนกับมีนัดมีสอน
เหมือนอย่าตอนนี้ที่ครูนิกสอนผ่านเว็บ
เว็บนึงแล้วทีนี้เขาก็จะเหมือนกับให้ซิง
ซิก็คือเหมือนเอาข้อมูลจากเว็บเค้าเข้า
โทรศัพท์ได้เข้าเข้าปฏิทินได้มันก็จะอยู่
ในนั้นหมดครับอออดีจังเลยแล้วก็มีวิธีการ
จัดการนัดหมายใช่มั้ยคะในโทรศัพท์ใชใน
โทรศัพท์แล้วมันก็จะมีเตือนให้ด้วยแล้ว
แต่เราจะเหมือนกับตั้งเตือนกี่ชั่วโมงกี่
นาทีก่อนเวลานัดครับปกติคุณนิดก็จะตั้ง
ไว้ครึ่งชั่วโมง
อื
เรมก็ใช้เหมือนกันนะส่วนตัวเรมเรมก็ใช้
เหมือนกันอืเรมก็ใช้ตอนแบบตื่นนอนอะไร
เงี้ย 6:00 นใช่มยคะเรมก็ใส่ไว้ใน
โทรศัพท์ถึงเวลา 18:00 นแล้วมันก็จะมี
เสียงติ๊ดๆๆๆๆๆๆๆ
ๆก็ตื่นละอืตื่นแล้วแบบก็ไปทำอะไรนะไป
ดื่มน้ำก่อนแล้วอีกสักพักนึงโทรศัพท์ก็จะ
ติ๊ดๆๆๆๆๆๆๆเรียมว่าดูอ๋อทำอะไรอีกอื
เพราะว่าเรามีการแบบพิมพ์แล้วก็ใส่ไว้ใน
นี้ตั้งแต่แรกอยู่แล้วใช่ใช่อือืก็ประมาณ
นั้นครับครุณนิดก็
จะใส่เอาไว้ในโทรศัพท์คือเมื่อก่อนน่ะ
ครุณนิดอ่ะจะไม่ชอบใส่อะไรในโทรศัพท์คุณ
นิจะเขียนเอาเขียนแล้วโน้ตแปะเอาไว้ใน
ห้องทำงานอืมแต่คุณนิดตอนนี้รู้สึกว่ามัน
เสียดายกระดาษเพราะว่าพอเขียนไปเสร็จแล้ว
ก็ทิ้งตอนนี้ทุกอย่างคุณนิก็เลยมาทำให้
มันอยู่ในโทรศัพท์ได้มากที่สุดอืเพราะว่า
เหมือนกับคือเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยคครูนิกไม่ได้
เป็นคนที่มีโทรศัพท์อยู่กับตัวตลอดเวลา
คุณนิกจะชอบแบบโทรศัพท์มันก็สมัยก่อนน่ะ
โทรศัพท์มันก็แค่ว่าปิดเปิดที่มันพับได้
มันทำอะไรไม่ได้จคุยโทรศัพท์กับส่งข้อ
ความมันก็เลยไม่ได้มีความสำคัญมากสำหรับ
ครูนิพอตอนนี้โทรศัพท์มันฉลาดขึ้นทีนี้ก็
เลยใส่ทุกอย่างไว้ในนี้ครับอือืแล้วเวลา
ที่ครูนิกจะจัดการเรื่องตารางเวลาเนี่ย
แบบยาวนานที่สุดเลยนะที่เราแบบวางแผนไว้
ว่าวันนี้อย่างเช่นวันเนี้ยเราก็วางแผน
ไว้แล้วแหละว่าจะทำอะไรเราก็ใส่ไว้ใน
โทรศัพท์พรุ่งนี้ก็แบบวางแผนไว้แล้วสส่วน
ตัวของเรียนนะวางแผนไว้ถึงแบบเดือนเป็น
เดือนอ่ะวางแผนล่วงหน้าเป็นเดือนใชเหของ
ของคครูนิกก็เหมือนกันครูนิกเคยเหมือนกับ
วางแผนแต่อันนั้นจะเป็นวางแผนแบบไปเที่ยว
หรือส่วนใหญ่จะเป็นไปเที่ยวมากกว่าที่ว่า
วางแผนไว้นานๆแล้วใส่ในใส่ในปฏิทินว่า
โอเคเดี๋ยวอีก 5 เดือนจะไปเที่ยวหาเพื่อน
ไปเยี่ยมปู่เยี่ยมย่าอะไรแบบเยครับก็จะมี
ใส่ไว้แบบนั้นเหมือนกัน
อืใช่ใช่แล้วเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยเรียนเป็นคน
ที่จดใส่กระดาษว่าวันนี้จะทำอะไรบ้างครับ
แล้วก็ไม่ได้เขียนเวลานะว่า 10:00 น 18:00
นไม่ได้เขียนเวลาแต่เขียนไว้ว่าจะทำอะไร
พอทำเสร็จแล้วเรียมก็ขีถูกคิดถูกคิดถูก
อ๋อแต่ว่ามันก็เกิดปัญหาขึ้น
ว่าบางทีอ่ะตอนเช้าเรารู้สึกขี้เกียจขี้
เกียจอืแล้วตอนเย็นก็ขี้เกียจจนถึงแบบ
กำลังค่ำๆอ่ะเราก็ดูเฮ้ยวันนี้ยังไม่ทำ
อะไรเลยที่เราเขียนไว้อเราก็จะแบบเฮ้ยทำ
เรารู้สึกมันยุ่งอ่ะยุ่งเออใช่มันเราดี
มันเหมือนกับคนนี้ก็เป็นนะเมื่อก่อนคือจะ
เรียกว่าเหมือนเป็นดินพอกหางหมูก็ได้ก็
คิดว่าเออตื่นมายังเช้าอยู่เลยไม่เห็น
ต้องรีบจะรีบทำทำไมเดี๋ยวค่อยทำก็ได้แล้ว
เก็บไว้จนอีก 1 ชมจะเที่ยงคืแล้วแบบอ้า
ต้องนอนแล้วนี่แต่ยังไม่ทำอะไรเสร็จสัก
อย่างก็เลยต้องรีบๆๆทำแล้วก็นอนอีกที 3:00
นแล้วคิดว่ามันไม่ดีก็เลยเปลี่ยนใช่ครับ
อืแล้วตอนนี้เป็นยังไงคะดีขึ้นว่าดีขึ้น
ดีขึ้นครับเพราะว่าพอเราจัดการเวลาได้
เค้าเหมือนกับมันเป็นระบบว่าพอจัดเวลาได้
แบบนี้แบบนี้แล้วทำตามมันมีเวลาว่างที่ไป
ทำอย่างอื่นได้ครับใช่คือเราจะไม่เสีย
เวลาทั้งวันอื
อืจริงเพราะว่าคุณนิอย่างง่ายๆเวลาตาราง
งานเนี่ยตารางงานครูนิกอันนี้อันนี้ไม่
ไม่แน่ใจว่าจะเกี่ยวกับที่ว่าการจัด
ปฏิทินมยแต่สำหรับคครูนิกครูนิกรู้สึกว่า
ครูนิกชอบทำงานตอนเช้ามากกว่าทำงานตอน
เย็น
เพราะไม่รู้ว่าไม่รู้ว่าครูเรียมเป็น
เหมือนกันมคือสำหรับครูนิกเนี่ยครูนิคิด
ว่าถ้าทำงานตอนเช้าเราตื่นเช้าทำงานเสร็จ
ถึงประมาณ 16 น 1700 นแล้วเรายังรู้สึก
ที่จะออกไปทำอะไรข้างนอกไปเดินเล่นไป
ช้อปปิ้งไปเจอเพื่อนออกกำลังกายได้แต่ถ้า
เราทำงานตอนบ่ายหรือตอนเย็นตอนเช้าเนี่ย
เราอย่างส่วนใหญ่ที่จะทำก็คือนอนจนตื่น
สายออแล้วก็อาบน้ำไปทำงานทำให้เหมือนกับ
เสียเวลาตอนเช้าไป
เลยอืใช่ๆเดมว่าเรียมก็เป็นเหมือนกันอือ
ส่วนใหญ่เรียมจะเริ่มทำงานตอน 7:00 นเอ้ย
ไม่จริงความจริง
อ่ะบางทีอาจจะเช้ากว่านั้นนะคือตอนเช้า
เรียมตื่น 6:00 นใช่มั้คะมาดื่มน้ำบางวัน
ก็แบบไปวิ่งบางวันก็โยคะบางวันก็วาดรูป
ตอนเช้าครับอืจากนั้นก็เริ่มงานจริงๆ 7:00
นอืเพราะคิดว่ามันแบบตอนเช้าแล้วได้แต่ง
หน้ามันพร้อมทุกอย่างแล้วอ่ะอือฮึแล้วก็
แบบทำงานหลังจากนั้นเราจะออกไปข้างนอกเรา
ก็มั่นใจแล้วเพราะว่าเออมันดูดีแล้วครับ
แต่วันไหนที่ไม่ได้ทำงานตอนเช้าเราก็จะ
ชุดนอนใช่ชุดนอนแล้วก็รู้สึกว่าเออไม่
อยากจะทำอะไรเยอะเพราะว่าเดี๋ยวงานมัน
เริ่มตอนบ่ายแล้วไม่รู้ว่างานมันจะยุ่ง
ขนาดขนาดไหนของคุณนิกนคือคุณนิกอยากจะไม่
รู้ว่างานมันจะยุ่งขนาดไหนก็เลยไม่อยากทำ
อะไรเยอะเพราะกลัวเดี๋ยวไม่มีแรง
อือ
[เพลง]
อือเก็บพลังงานเก็บแรงไว้ก่อนงานเอาไว้
เพราะว่าคือเพราะเหมือนกับของคุณนี้เนี่ย
งานที่ทำมันจะเป็นงานเกี่ยวกับต้องเจอลูก
ค้าต้องเจอกับคนแล้วมันต้องใช้พลังงาน
เยอะในการคุยถ้ามีปัญหามันต้องไปแก้อีก
แล้วบางทีมันมันเหมือนพยายามอยากจะ
เคลียร์ให้ตัวเองโล่งก่อนที่จะไปเริ่มงาน
อ๋อแล้วพอหลังจากที่ครูนิกเริ่มทำงานตอน
เช้าแล้วล่ะเปลี่ยนแบบมาทำงานตอนเช้าด้วย
มันเป็นยังไงทำงานตอนบ่ายยังโอเคมั้ยคุณ
นิก็จริงๆทำงานตอนบ่ายก็ยังโอเคเพราะว่า
ตอนนี้เนี่ยคือเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยมันก็อย่าง
ที่ครูนิกบอกว่าครูนิกก็จะตื่นสายใกล้ๆ
เวลาเริ่มงานตอนบ่ายไปเลยแต่ว่าทุกวันนี้
เนี่ยครูนิกเปลี่ยนว่าถึงจะถึงจะทำงานตอน
เช้าหรือทำงานตอนบ่ายคุณนิกก็จะตื่นเวลา
เดิมอืใช่ก็จะตื่นตอนตอนนี้ทุกวันนี้คุณ
นิกจะตื่นประมาณ 8:00
น 7:00 น 8:00 นแล้วแต่ครับแล้วก็พยายาม
หาอะไร
ทำในเวลาที่มันว่างอืใช่แล้วเวลาที่เรา
จัดตารางแล้วสิ่งที่ครูนิกคิดว่าตารางที่
ครูนิกให้ความสำคัญที่
สุดในตารางนั้นน่ะที่เราจัดเป็นเรื่อง
อะไรของเรียมเนี่ยคิดว่าเรื่องงาน
อืมเรื่องอะไรคุณนิก็คงคิดว่าน่าจะเป็น
เรื่องงานเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดว่าเราไม่ให้
ความสำคัญกับงานหรือตารางงานเราจะโดนไล่
ออกใช่แต่บางคนเค้าแบบให้ความสำคัญเรื่อง
เร่องสุขภาพต้องตื่นเป็นเวลานอนเร็วมีแบบ
จัดตารางไปออกกำลังกายครับสำหรับครูนิก
เนี่ยเรื่องนอนครูนิกจะไม่ได้ซีเรียสมาก
คือครูนิกจะคิดว่าอย่างน้อยต้องนอน 8 ชมง
ดังนั้นไม่จำเป็นว่าต้อง 22:00 นทุกวัน
หรือ 23 นทุกวันครุณนิก็จะดูไปว่า
โอเคถ้านอนเที่ยงคืต้องตื่น 8 น 7 ก็ได้
คุณนิก็จะเฉลี่ยไว้ว่านอนสำหรับคุณนิจะ
นอน 6-8 ชมงดังนั้นถ้าคุนิเริ่มนอนเมื่อ
ไหร่ก็จะตั้งไว้ว่าต้องตื่นเวลานี้มันก็
เลยไม่ได้ถามว่าให้ความสำคัญมให้ความ
สำคัญส่วนนึงแต่จะไม่ต้องตายตัวว่าต้อง
เวลานี้เท่านั้นแล้วต้องตื่นเวลานี้เท่า
นั้นครับอืออกกำลังกายก็เหมือนกันของครู
นิกเนี่ยก็จะครูนิกจะตั้งว่าออกกำลังกาย
อาทิตย์ละ 4-5  5 ครั้งจะวันไหนก็ได้เวลา
ไหนก็ได้ครับอืแต่ต้องมีอย่างน้อย 4-5
ครั้งแล้วก็ครั้งละครึ่งชั่วโมงครับ
อืแล้วถ้าสมมุติว่ามีแบบคนมานัดหรือว่าขอ
ร้องให้ครูนิกทำอะไรแล้วมันชนกับเวลาที่
ครูนิกอยากทำในสิ่งที่ครูนิกอยากทำที่มัน
ไม่ใช่เรื่องงานนะจะทำยังไงก็ถ้ามันไม่
ได้เป็นอะไรที่สำคัญคครูนิกก็จะครูนิก็จะ
ไปช่วยเขาได้สมมุติถ้ามีเพื่อนแบบว่าเออ
เนี่ยพอดีมีเรื่องมีปัญหาบอกว่าเออทะเลาะ
กับแฟนไม่รู้จะคุยกับใครอยากเจอไปกินข้าว
คุณนึก็อ่าคือครูนิกเนี่ยจะให้ความสำคัญ
กับความรู้สึกปัญหาเกี่ยวกับความรู้สึก
เพราะว่าครูนิกมองว่าถ้าเขามานัดเราหรือ
อยากเจอเราเนี่ยคือเขาเลือกแล้วอ่ะว่าเค
มีปัญหาแบบแบบเนี้ยอยากหาที่ระบายอยากหา
คนพูดคุยด้วยอคุณนิกก็จะคุณนิก็จะโอเคได้
ก็ไปหาเลยแล้วก็ที่คุณนิกแพลนไว้ว่าจะออก
กำลังกายหรือไปทำอะไรที่ไม่สำคัญก็ยกเลิก
ไปก่อนอือันนั้นคนนี้ก็จะมองว่าเป็น
เรื่องเป็นจะใช้คำว่าเป็นเหตุฉุกเฉินก็
ได้อืเราก็คิดว่ามันยืดหยุ่นได้ใช่มั้ย
มันยืดหยุ่นได้มันไม่ได้ฟิกฟิฟิขนาดนั้นอ
มันไม่ได้ฟิกแบบต้องเวลานี้เหมือนอย่าง
ตารางงาน
อ๋อแล้วของทุกๆคนล่ะคะเป็นยังไงใช่อยาก
รู้เหมือนกันว่านักเรียนมีการจัดตารางงาน
ยังไงว่ายืดหยุ่นได้มยถ้ามีปัญหานี้จะ
ขยับไปทำตอนอื่นหรือเปล่าใช่หรือว่ามี
วิธีการจัดการตารางงานยังไงเขียนบันทึึก
ไว้ในโทรศัพท์หรือว่าทำแบบไหนกันใช่หรือ
จำไว้ในนี้มีนะบางคนก็จำไว้ในนี้ตลอดว้าว
สุดยอดแต่แค่เรียมทำไม่ได้คู่นี้ก็ทำไม่
ได้แล้วตอนนี้ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้ก็หมด
เวลาแล้วใช่ไหมมต้องไปแล้วเนาะโอเคใช่
ต้องไปแล้วค่ะต้องเจอกันใหม่ในคลิปหน้า
แล้วค่ะทุกคนได้ครับครูเรียมไว้เจอกัน
ใหม่นะครับนักเรียนทุกคน
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนบ๊ายบายบบ